this is a terrible terrible secret
i'm always thinking of the joke
don't think about anything else
there is a vast vast hunger
for new talent and you can be it and
overcoming a lack of talent
often makes you unique instead of
conventional singing you're going to
sing in a different way
instead of conventional dancing you're
going to dance your own way
in fact if you start with nothing the
workaround
can lead you to originality
we're going to talk about a lot of
things we're going to talk about my
specific
process thank you performing comedy hey
move that over there we're going to talk
about writing
editing is one of your most powerful
tools
see that bit's not working it's gone the
next night
now what gets the laugh whenever it's
the word
that gets the laugh i always question it
an ultimate goal of mine is to work
clean
well then you should take off yeah
i never actually thought i was funny you
may think
i don't have any talent i guarantee you
i
had no talent none
remember you are a thought machine
everything you see here experience
is usable oh what oh
whatever makes you unique as a performer
do it
and know that there's room for you
hey welcome to steve martin's
masterclass
[Music]
huh
[Music]
you